[Music]
welcome back to the break room
uh wow uh welcome back to the break room
live from new rockstars hq uh we are
very excited we've got a lot of news
it's san diego comic-con weekend
we've got a ton
of marvel animated news
in addition wwe long time ceo of vince
mcmahon finally stepped down formally
we're on twitter we've got we've got
gremlins casting news we've got uh a
four second national treasure uh series
teaser we'll be covering none of that
today this is gonna be entirely
dedicated to covering the san diego
comic-con marvel animation panel a lot
of news came out of which we are very
excited about x-men 1997 spider-man
freshman year what if season two marvel
zombies i am groot
is that everything i think that was
that's enough hey that's enough i like
calling it x-men 1997.
i like it
you got to place the gotta let them know
let them know i mean what percentage of
our audience was not born
i don't want that
um so uh we're gonna we're gonna start
at the top with x-men 97 1997. 2097 who
knows
whatever you want to refer to
you can go back and forth um so throw in
the chat your thoughts on the news your
questions about the series
anything else this is also i believe
chronologically
after i am groot this is the first
animated thing we're going to get i
believe is that correct mm-hmm the
what-if or the
and then fall for x-men i think that's
what they said uh and you know let's
go ahead and introduce folks that guy
with a vague understanding of the
release calendar is mr john costa
apologies in advance for all the if we
have any technical problems today we put
a show together in an hour and a half
yes hey we're breaking news today we've
got uh with a stack of notes that wolf
blitzer would be envious uh we got we've
got brandon barrack over there i'll
fight you wolf blitzer meet me in the
ring
and then uh uh also joined by our
wonderful friend mr erica wussu hey
everybody happy friday happy san diego
comic-con yes
yes noted miles morales cosplayer erica
wussu um he gave me away
he's been threatening to show up in that
costume honor
[Laughter]
quick plug we are on tick tock the break
room is on tick tock at the underscore
break room mostly tommy bechtol posting
really fun content there content you
will not see on the actual break room
follow us there we appreciate it we're
trying to build a small community there
uh okay but let's get into it first off
uh we got this huge
uh marvel animation panel where they
covered a lot of upcoming content this
was not streamed anywhere basically all
of our information is coming from a
series of journalist tweets and some um
hastily taken screen grabs of animation
cells that we will be sharing with you
uh we want to talk first and foremost
about x-men this has been mentioned
before we knew this was in the works
this is a continuation of the 90s x-men
animation series of which the theme song
we've heard a lot of lately
[Music]
yes
um and the the new information we got
some kind of full squad reveals as it
were some of the characters that are
going to be in this show good guys bad
guys good guys bad guys both uh and kind
of the big reveal magneto is gonna be
running the x-men
yeah the hot the hot news out of that
part of the panel for sure yeah you have
you've seen all of x-men 97 oh it's been
a while since i watched those cartoons
oh yes xavier is off world is that yeah
yeah the series kind of ends spoiler if
you're what if you're going through the
series now go through it if you've right
a couple days
some of you were just born i know but uh
uh yeah i kind of end with xavier
injured sent off to space to be with his
shiar honey
and kind of like heal up in space and at
this point in the story magneto and the
x-men are kind of getting along season
five has a lot of interesting team-ups
in it uh and so yeah magneto's kind of
like left in charge because you know
at their core xavier and eric are good
friends and they love each other they
want the same thing they just have
different means of achieving it yes uh
and i would just like to go on record
and say magneto was right
magneto was right
um now speaking of right or wrong what
are your thoughts on this costume do we
have the image of the magnet there you
go i love the hair
i mean eric sleeveless with the high
glove
and then obviously the locks are flowing
no helmet and a big old lamb
yeah i don't know i can't explain why
but like long white hair in animation
always reads as like unhinged villain to
me yeah and so
i hate sephiroth
there was like a great run in uh new
x-men when like magneto's high on kick
which was like a drug that made like
newton's power stronger he's like high
as hell he takes over manhattan he uses
his magnetic powers to like rip up the
bridges uh and it's great and then at
some point he's like oh man i gotta i
gotta get better
he's on the down yeah he goes on the
down the bottom is like getting divorced
and yeah he's getting their job that's
like definitely a long hair magneto time
and it's great oh it's very crazy if
there's ever any a place to go to have a
bender as a music go to manhattan in
1997. yeah this is also and again
they're being very kind of like accurate
to the era that kind of um chris
claremont chris claremont era that a lot
of us fell in love with his kids right
but like that big-ass m on his chest
great that was that was part of that era
right daredevil with two huge d's on the
middle of his chest like how will they
know who i am unless i have my emotions
those comic panels could be kind of
small sometimes
i'm a frost with two huge d's on earth
how dare you i was a young man
but speaking of emma frost who was in
some of the promo images for this show
she will be part of the bad
bad folks in this series the enemies but
um the heroes we got a great um
squad photo there there it is the squad
uh a lot of our favorites rogue gambit
wolverine jubilee cyclops storm jean
grey and beast
blue glory
that's a great i also got to take a
moment shout out that cell animation man
none of this
that real hand-drawn look right um
they've probably advanced the technology
using computers to do it and hopefully
it looks good but uh yeah i love that
they did not change the style too much
it's really interesting when what if
came out we were sort of like oh is this
the animation style they're gonna do for
all of the marvel animated shows and i'm
so glad it's not you know uh spider-man
freshman year which we're gonna get to
in a minute look also looks incredible
uh the i am groot show is just like full
hyper realistic uh
yeah i love that they're like oh no
we're gonna do whatever makes the most
sense for the show well and that that
hints at a big question all of us have
about this animated content
how canon is it right to the live action
content and to each other
that's a good that's a good question do
we think you know i i don't i don't know
how any of these animated shows could
cross into each other well we rely on
like the quotes that came out when the
first what if was coming out right where
they kind of said then like all the
animated stuff is canon
uh in that we now know there's
multiverses and there's different
timelines and blah blah blah but they
also at that same time were saying some
of these
animated characters could cross over
into live action now in hindsight they
were probably saying that to set us up
for like seeing peggy carter as captain
carter well and put a pin in that we're
gonna get that later and for seeing like
an evil doctor trade just so it like
made sense then but those were different
and all that so
i think it's canon and it's canon right
yeah
right you're right yeah i think it's
canon unless they say it's not cat
because like when i saw dr strange
multiverse madness and he had like the
snake dragons coming out of his hands
and all that stuff that was from
multiverse kind of oh sorry that was
from what if right
he absorbs some of those demons and
whatnot well and i will get to i'm groot
in a second but james gunn about i am
groot sort of said it's its own canon
and so i think like marvel's always
gonna be like yep it's canon
this is what comic book readers have
always dealt with right where it's like
you know your favorite characters can
really change depending on who's writing
it well and it's all kind of canon but
not canon and there's three
at least three spider-man comics coming
out every month telling totally
different stories unrelated to each
other right um well it feels like maybe
marvel's trying to have a little both
ways dc long ago was like nah tv flash
isn't the same as movie that's right
and animated uh harley quinn is not the
same as film or whatever right um maybe
feels like marvel's like no you need to
watch all of this you can't skip any of
this right we'll talk to you later
um oh also oh we got another great x-men
asset i believe this one's showing off
oh throw it up there yes okay this one's
showing off a different group of heroes
sunspot morph
cable
bishop forge and nightcrawler uh a great
again tucker when you want to talk about
90s x-men x-force if you don't have
cable with some big goofy guns in there
baby what are you even doing in the
pockets what are you even doing without
some pockets guys just my boy morphs
hair
oh yeah yeah hey long curly hair yeah he
had a good locks before well i mean when
you're a shape shifter in theory he can
create his own right yes i guess he
could like chameleon was always bald uh
but morph usually has a little lack of
hair sunspot is was never on
x-men 1997 in 1997. right so he's like
yeah that's edition he's a newer dish
interesting uh i will say looking at
that photo reminded me a little new
rockstar's exclusive my very good friend
and former roommate uh is writing on
x-men 97 and uh
we were drunk at a night out once and he
might be on fire he couldn't he couldn't
he couldn't see what project he was
working on it was like several several
it was like a year ago before it had
been announced
all he would say he was pretty much here
bishop
and i was like i was like are we getting
a just a whole bishop show are you sure
you weren't drunkenly playing chess with
him yeah
the bishop
i believe also uh front of the program
frank moran i believe all of you might
be working on that program uh tell your
friend and we'll tell frank come on the
show
come on the show you count
uh and then also we got a great i love a
good lineup pic too you know what i mean
such a comic book thing to get that one
image of the of the squad or a big trunk
of the squad uh we gotta look at the
villains as well do we have that asset
ready to throw up
or hopefully it doesn't make us throw up
i don't know if we do have that if not
that's okay but um it seemed to be
centered around mr sinister
uh looks like he's gonna be a big part
of this we got sebastian sebastian shaw
the white queen of course as we
mentioned uh emma frost callisto and
then val cooper good old val cooper yeah
she's like uh she works for the
government she usually like works i
think with the secretary of state or i
don't know she's like a government
insider and they were kind of teasing at
the panel i guess like don't trust this
lady
she's a bad government lady bad news wow
bad news and now there's not to be
confused with another vowel from live
not the other boundaries yes yeah who
also works for the also works for the
government also not to be trusted yeah
um apparently at the panel we don't have
this but they showed an animatic of the
x-men with morph fighting sentinels
again huge part of that series was kind
of the constant battles with sentinels
uh rogue ripping off the sentinel's head
hell yeah
uh it's saying heads up
i guess the jokes are going to be there
too yeah
that's something we were sort of trying
to decide between this group was what is
the tone of the show right i guess is it
for kids is it going to kind of age with
the people who were maybe watching it in
97
i don't know uh marvel zombies is going
to be rated tvma i don't think this show
is going to go there but i do think
they'll try to kind of give this show to
its original fans us right i mean when
you go back and watch like the series uh
the original series it is interesting
because it is drawn
so much like the comic books and it
looks so adult it's just like you know
the lines are a little softer and the
storylines are a little more accessible
but it's like a pretty adult it's about
adults the only kid on the show is
usually like jubilee or like kids in
trouble somewhere like yeah she's
usually our window into yeah yeah this
was like very comic book and we've had
some like heavy stuff characters dying
morph
more
like messed up stuff
i want to quickly shout out a couple of
folks sending us super chats we
appreciate you thank you alex clark
erickson diaz thank you so much and then
smoothie with a great uh super chat i
think it would be epic for all the break
room fans to wear trash bags to the next
comments i mean depending on how hot it
is next year we might have to it was
just indoors
hey if you're trying to cut weight for a
wrestling mate yeah yeah
makes sense thank you uh bryce burris uh
house of the dragon or rings of power oh
you know we're not talking about this
we're not gonna get to that yet but
that's gonna be a big debate over the
next couple weeks here at new rockstars
which of those series are folks gonna be
more jazzed about which is gonna turn
out better who has better wigs who has i
mean the wig game on both those shows
better be yeah
a1 uh the budgets the wig budgets um and
the final couple things on xbox 97
they've already ordered season two
yes we're getting the uh season one in
theory next year fall of 2023 yeah
roughly 12 months from now a little
farther uh and then season two we don't
know when but yeah exciting do you think
about what if you think okay that's
probably coming out sometime in 2025
right
uh they do two years apart for these
images well maybe though maybe they
might be up on it maybe this whole early
a lot of the a lot of the series we're
talking about they've already kind of
started talking about two seasons so
maybe that is a little peter jackson
lord of the rings let's let's get the
production rolling so we can get that
second season a little faster
um
uh great we've got some other great
comments we want to get to from you the
viewer thank you so much uh
danielle why asking will i need to watch
the og x-men series to understand what
is happening
i i mean i don't know i don't know but i
i would think that they'll make it
accessible they won't expect everyone to
go watch the five seasons if you can
watch it go watch it well it jumps
around there's like they do little story
arcs within seasons like two episode
three episode story arcs so maybe a look
up a best dove list
something we uh oh oh someone might be
coming out so what might be coming in
something we didn't touch on in these
notes is that they're putting uh the
original series on disney plus and
they're reordering yeah they had the
order wrong originally when they put
them out okay like there's a part
there's a sequence where jean grey's
gone and all of a sudden she's back and
then she's gone again and it's it's very
confusing
oh no we've got a special guest
appearance
oh no it's me they said there weren't
enough dudes on this episode
sweet t-shirt
for the viewers at home uh he does smell
like sunscreen so he's like really
completing the image yes hi everyone oh
wow t-circles
i'm uh
on the eve of my vacation
you know i've been i've been hard at
work uh i wanted to make some
surprise announcements give notes okay i
wanted to make some surprise comic-con
announcements on friday in honor you
might need the intro we haven't gotten
to tumblecon yet so uh real quick do you
want to tell them what comic-con is
comic-con is a way of life
it's a church that i'm starting a
grassroots church no uh
it's a celebration of it's the signature
south uh southern california pop culture
event of the century
uh
we're hosting such things as justfest
uh the brandon barrack four minute
soapbox the celebration to jessica
clemens a three-minute video celebration
uh zach huddleston singing the blues
but
we have some new events to announce oh
my god i wrote them down for you guys i
gotta just i'm sorry i don't have them
off the top of my head
uh
the eyes are here
i believe we pray
okay great guys i am now happy to
announce amongst the exclusives
uh some other people appearing at
comic-con they'll be horse funerals oh
divorce dad bingo
smush the world's number one slash
impersonator he's four foot three and
full of guitar energy
snakes snake snakes
chris pine total blackouts
fart simpson
daily blood pressure checks
former surgeon general joyce
brothers right-wing muppet running for
senate in pennsylvania santa jaws
maury the cool guy rabbi
rapping toddlers reverse strippers my
uncle doug
salon quality haircuts by britney
hashtag free brittany
a big update on gucci and moochie also
my ex-wife will be serving me legal
documents during the one-hour crying
panel in hall h
so uh look forward to all of that wow
we're gonna do all that live on youtube
monday this upcoming monday thanks for
giving generously and remember
the more money that goes into this the
more they're gonna let me spend on this
comic-con so give generously
no i've got to go perform a wedding
that's which is a true story well you're
dressed for the wedding yeah not
officiating out of ten you're performing
performing
officiating wow
weddings are like surgical procedures
for me
performed the surgery i performed the
wedding fart simpson is a gas
now wrapping toddlers how is that spout
wrapping
there's definitely two peas
uh and they will be wrapping uh w-r-a oh
is licensed by macy's to gift wrap from
december 1st to january i like this idea
of toys unboxing tablets
oh we're yes that's we're doing a toys
for not struck
that's where we we donate toys to give
to the staff at knott's berry farm
because all those mean teens are running
i was gonna ask how you spelled it
wow i was thinking hot or not so that's
that's we're finally giving them their
gifts
which is an all-female beatles cover
band oh wow it's just broken
wow thank you so much
wow
keep it
gucci to
[Music]
when he can't make the full show he
makes sure to uh make a guest appearance
yes as we've been uh promoting all week
monday after comic-con comes the tamicon
okay because we were able to raise
enough money this week via super chats
and your wonderful donations uh tommy
gets to go nuts on monday you won't want
to miss it we that that's only a taste
of the kind of insanity that will be
taking place we don't even know what's
going to happen uh but tommy will have
full control of this show and things are
going to get wet and wild i think it's
safe to say the hundred men went into
the water that night
came out uh also i think that counts
right retroactively as our mandatory
fund for the day uh tommy's a guest
appearance play the graphic that's right
there it is
it's such a laugher we play the graphic
after okay um
uh okay back to the san diego comic-con
uh marvel animation panel uh we covered
a lot of the x-men 97 news we got to
move on to the series
okay i'm excited about all of them but
maybe my second
most interested uh spider-man freshman
year
um
jessica says jubilee is made no no she's
telling me to say and i refuse to say it
okay oh
disgusting
jessica decided to stay home
all right jessica clemens just spent ten
dollars to super chat to force brandon
to say that jubilee is made here's one
she's a 10 but she says jubilee is mid
that makes her a joke jessica got her
all right now now unconfirmed but the
rumor around the new rockstars office is
that brandon is mostly a jubilee stand
because he does a really good cosplay
over here
there are photos there are photos
reviving it for tomicon no i don't have
if it were true i don't think i have the
jacket anymore yeah the iconic yellow
the iconic yellow jacket um okay but
back uh to the comic-con news spider-man
freshman year
um a couple big reveals
huge including charlie cox will be
voicing daredevil
in the black suit in the black yeah yeah
we've got a photo the little loved black
suit oh daredevil look at that this is
good bye tommy that looks sleek uh yeah
this is like really cool that we're
gonna see daredevil on this and
obviously this is like
uh cannon the jace is what we're saying
like six one six a jace
like it's gonna follow a lot of the same
points you you see doctor straight we
have i think a picture of doctor strange
maybe we didn't pull this one doctor
strange like helping peter at school
and like you know they didn't know each
other and it wouldn't when he was a
freshman so
also another big reveal for the show uh
norman and harry osborne both going to
be featured in this show and as was
established in no way home
well you know that's a spongy it's a
spongy girl he says he says i couldn't
find oscorp yeah maybe
not you know you don't want me to fall
it's not a well-known name yeah
it's not a huge multinational
corporation or something like that but i
would i would love a version of oz corp
that was like uh you know
uh deep inside of oh no like like uh
deep inside of like a shell corporation
so it's hiding its operations a little
bit
uh i was just dangling to get skunk
works out on the show um yeah but those
are two and also uh i apologize i'm
probably gonna butcher this name nico
minoru
does that sound right from runaways
we'll be playing uh the best friend um
tom holland will not be voicing
peterborough not voicing peter pan we
don't know who will be
john seems to think it might be the
person we don't we always do
in um
what if we don't know who it will be the
person who did it in what if did an
excellent job i had no idea it wasn't
tom holland until after the fact um
so i wouldn't we don't know we don't
know in like uh though not a ton of plot
details for this show but we're kind of
assuming it's kind of picking up right
this is it's called freshman year this
is an early peter maybe not exactly
origin story but like he's still
figuring your stuff out right like the
costume he wears is very rudimentary
it's a little bone saw yeah
right where he keeps his web fluid in
like a camelback basically
we have that got a nice little jansport
back there yes there's a bunch of
different costumes yeah he's gonna go
through a couple different levels but at
least one that we saw was him with kind
of a very duct-tapey
um goggle
sneakers that's like the original
costume we met him in homecoming yeah uh
the very makeshift oh there you go there
he is
uh you get a sense of it there norman
rich
powerful also he has a hopefully i hope
from that picture the waves on swift
there's always hay yeah it's always
expected to have wavy red black hair
yeah black people love norman osborne
possibly just because that's an easy
thing for
somebody to it's a drama
but it's not easy to get or maintained
yeah we need to know norman osborn's
night routine all right
put him in a do-rag every night
uh yeah now uh we also got some great uh
again a good some good lineup picks of
the villains that are gonna be showing
up in this series yes i love it look at
that a classic looking doctor octopus uh
we got a scorpion in there we got a um
who else uh uh a chameleon i know action
yes rhino is going to be appearing as
well as some like maybe lesser known
figures who do not immediately come to
mind when i look at this i will say
you just kind of look goony you know yes
uh some random baddies um good guns
great good good
good love to see it um also another one
season two already ordered something and
this show this show doesn't even come
out until 2024. yeah they don't know
they're gonna do a whole other panel for
this yeah
this was the most disappointing news i
know that was the biggest moment i think
like spiderman animated shows or just
money every time they've done them
forever they've always since
the the fox one uh when i was a young
lad this was hot on the heels of like
the x-men i mean even the origin of the
spider-man meme you could go way
like there's you know spiderman and
friends i think yeah it's like a kids
show
uh yeah it's always been been very very
profitable
rarely has we had television without an
animated spider-man so it's interesting
but this is going to be the kind of like
mcu-ish disney plus maybe a little
higher budget a little bigger names
maybe a little bit more adult content we
don't know or not adult that makes it
sound dirty but you know what i mean a
little bit more mature story lines
we're very excited throw in the chat
what what are your feelings about
spider-man freshman year uh jazzed
hyper-jazzed ultra-jazzed um
i mean i i know sometimes people
complain for batman movies or something
like that like how many times do we have
to see the origin story oh the broken i
want to see
the shot
even in the sequel
you know what i never get tired of
though
that that sequence of peter learning his
powers right
with things coming out of his wrist i'm
here for it i'm here for it um
this show looks like a lot of fun again
i like the animation style it looks
closer to x-men 97
very similar yeah yeah we did we did put
a poll in the chat which uh spider-man
villain you most excited for
uh i agree with the winner of this the
osbournes with 57
yeah i've been anchoring for osborne in
the mcu for a long time i know this this
whole sony
um disney debate there but uh i couldn't
be more excited yeah willem defoe killed
it in um
happy birthday willem dafoe oh yeah
i believe today is his
72nd holy christie in the chat help us
out is it 72 or 76. he's always never
said his age on the end he's older than
you think because he's still ripped and
uh and spry but uh happy happy birthday
um forever my norman
okay we're jazzed even though like
put a pin in it we're not getting
uh spider-man freshman year for a long
time yeah put your jazz aside
hang your jazz in a comfortable spot we
can easily reach it in a year also
hoping that they bring back aunt bae
because i miss her so much
sorely miss can't wait to see her and
spider-man freshman year yeah yeah oh
that's a good point we don't know well
we get a little happy hogan in there
maybe
a couple couple super chats we want to
shout out our good friend paintamenti
asking will there be a ball pit in
tomicon uh
it's good you might have just given
tommy an idea
let's see how many uh how many plastic
balls it would take to fill up this room
uh we might find out um some other uh
super chats
uh we'll get to later again throw it in
the chat your thoughts on freshman year
uh we're going to after a quick word
from our sponsors we're going to cover i
am groot we're going to cover what if
season two we're gonna cover marvel
zombies marvel zombies i was not
expecting to look as cool as it does
looks very cool um
speaking of very cool we want to give a
quick shout out to our friends at
betterhelp uh for sponsoring the break
room all week we appreciate you better
help we appreciate uh also um all our
fans all our
viewers our audience for signing up for
better help using our promo code uh
going into that url that's on screen
right now we appreciate you a bunch of
folks on new rockstar staff tommy's
talked about it this week but several
folks on our staff are currently using
better help have used better help
recently have family members that have
used better help we're big proponents
both have better help and of therapy in
general be it online in person however
you go about it um whether you need to
worry about specters standing behind you
oh no that's
that's john costa that's not a god
uh or or you know stress anxiety all the
things that come up in the course of our
normal lives better help's a great place
to go for that online therapy uh through
betterhelp they'll assess your needs and
can match you with your own licensed
professional therapist in less than 48
hours um and you don't have to take our
word for it we've been giving personal
testimonies this week but here's a quote
from a real better help uh user who's
not an employee at new rockstars um in
in uh talking about their experience
with real better health therapist
victoria neal victoria's an amazing
listener she's attentive and always
picking up on the little things that you
might not realize you're feeling or
saying i feel amazing during and after
our sessions a non-judgmental safe space
it's a pretty nice endorsement uh and
again if you um want to sign up for
betterhelp which we would encourage they
have a special offer for our breakers
our roomies our br heads um get 10 off
your first month of
therapy at betterhelp.com
room that's 10 off your first month of
online therapy at betterhelp.com
breakroom thank you betterhelp for
sponsoring us all week and then it is
friday which means it's fresh-based
fridays sponsored by our friends at
geology whoa eric giving us a little
vogue action um
uh if we cut to the wide shot here john
um
uh he there was a purpose behind him
sneaking behind me he was grabbing some
uh geology
products um geology our skin care
friends they have a great um you can go
and you can pick yourself up some nice
geology products with the the link
that's on screen at a big old discount
um they have a great test you can take
online you tell them what your issues
are you got you worried about wrinkles
maybe you got acne maybe you got oily
skin maybe you got dry skin whatever it
might be you put that in they pop out
like hey here's the perfect stuff for
you like their everyday face wash
they're repairing night cream
night cream it also sounds like could be
an x-men villain
that's not carla's cousin
night cream night crawler
they have everything you need for a
really tight skin care routine right to
fix what ails you you don't need to know
a bunch of stuff what kind of cream do i
get what kind of wash what kind of
lotion they'll figure that out for you
um they've hooked us up with a bunch of
these products and we're big fans of
geology products here
nine time award-winning men's skincare
company nine times they've won awards um
click the link in this video's
description or go to the url that's
being shown on on screen right now take
that quiz they'll figure out all the
dermatologists recommended stuff that
will suit you fix your face up to be the
best possible face it can be um and
they'll send you a 30-day trial set
that's easy to incorporate into your
routine whether you're new to skin care
or a seasoned expert um
they're offering a crazy deal you can
get 70 off their 30-day five-piece trial
kit 70 off that's they're practically
giving it away folks uh head to
geology.com to get 70 off on your 30-day
trial when use the code
rockstars70 or click the link below
that's geology.com promo code rockstar70
save 70 off on your free or on your 30
day trial thank you very much to geology
sponsored fresh face fridays
okay
john i blew it earlier i did say that
tommy's appearance was the mandatory
foot that's okay
we can call this compulsory fun
compulsory yeah obligatory fun uh we've
been talking about all of the marvel
comic-con announcements that have
happened today but there's a lot more
news that's going to happen tomorrow and
speaking of which zachary
uh eric zachariah is technically my name
but i'll accept coach
jonathan i worked for you i've worked
with you for three years and here i'm
learning new things um
zachariah eric jessica clemens who's in
the chat messing around right now i uh
also screen probably probably off screen
maybe on screen
we'll find out uh tomorrow we're gonna
be here
5 pm pacific time to talk about all of
the warner brothers announcements talk
about all the marvel live action
announcements but with those two things
in mind for tomorrow we thought we'd
like put in our final
thoughts our final predictions for what
could be coming tomorrow so i'm gonna
play a little game with you guys
how this game is going to work is i'm
going to give you two scenarios and i
want you guys to pick which is more
likely to happen
they might not happen either way one of
the other but i want you guys to decide
which one is the most likely to happen
okay
i'll also mention we uh if people in the
chat are talking about that it's like um
uh marvel like trademarked a bunch of
names for things today
uh
we talked about it in the office a
little bit you can't really put stock in
those kinds of things unconfirmed some
of it could be video games could be
video games
but like if you're a smart person
protecting your ip you should just
copyright everything right um so we're
not taking any of that into
consideration we have no idea what's
going to be announced tomorrow um but uh
first question marvel uh what's more
likely marvel announces their big team
up do we think it'll be either an
avengers story team-up film or a young
avengers team-up film which is more
likely between folks
yeah yeah
yeah they've been setting up they've
been setting up young adventures for a
while but uh but you know who doesn't
want another avengers film uh i'll go
first here i'm gonna say young avengers
to me sounds like a disney plus series
not to relegate it to the basement of
the mcu or anything like that i think
it'll be a really good disney plus
series but it feels a little bit more
that energy than than big screen uh
release so i'm going to say grown folks
avengers
avengers eric yeah giving them the
defender's treatment okay all right
the runaways they're damaged
uh wow i i really think we're gonna see
young avengers okay on the big screens i
think that's gonna be a big event
because you're right they have been
teeing up these young avengers members
left and right in recent years ever
since real quick rundown of potential
young avengers that have already been
established kate bishop already been
established we know stature is going to
be in the ant-man quantum media film uh
miss marvel miss marvel um there's also
uh scott wang's daughter stature stature
original og black captain america's
grandson uh isaiah bradley yeah yes i
think is his name yeah and then like
elena can be either you could put her on
young avengers or you could probably
think you have to right well i mean i
think she's more of a thunderbolts type
character well i i would say she'd be
the most moral person on thunder and we
know we know in the future in the not
too distant future we're getting riri
williams yeah that's right there's
rooney and wicken running around iron
heart is is um oh you know
williams right well tommy wicking are
they running around
somewhere out there there's a version
around we
potential and we'll probably be getting
a lot more potential
mania black panther two maybe yes okay
do you have a do you have an option here
yeah i think the lights will dim out
well kevin fight you'll be like one last
thing before i go it'll say avengers on
the screen people will start screaming
and then it will say
they'll be like not a grown they'll be
like
okay and i always say because like i
know more young avengers as we just
listed then who's an avenger right now
right they aren't great they've made a
big damn wilson captain america they've
made a big point and saying like the
avengers were gone even though like dr
stranger was like we'll get you back on
the lunch box like dr strange you're not
avenger what are you talking about he
never was
everybody was an adventure at the end of
the end game
okay okay okay uh here's the wild card
uh we know uh one of these shows has
wrapped one of these shows is shooting
right now do we think we'll see a clip
from
what's more likely loki season two
or secret invasion secret invasion
coming out a little bit sooner yeah but
loki season two everyone's salivating
we're getting those great set picks from
loki season two can i say both
no you can't
say both likely what's more likely and
boy they have been tight-lipped about
secret invasion we know a lot of casting
news but no no set photos
a photo of nick fury with an eye patch
wasn't there a photo of a newspaper that
had uh uh what's his face shaking hands
that we think is the new president yeah
uh
now don't put it past marvel to give us
like a literally one one and a half
second clip that's what we got for
secretary of state
that's why i think i'm gonna lean loki
on this just because like i think tom
hiddleston is so big and people loved
loki season one
and i think they're like uh we'll give
them a little lucky they don't need to
do what they do they could even show us
a clip from season one sure and just
with loki season two underneath it right
yeah but i'm gonna say secret invasion
i'm saying secret innovation yeah i
agree i think uh because we had loki
already i think secret invasion is a
good way to introduce some scrolls some
like
some fun stuff some more nick fury with
his glassy foggy eye in the mix get a
flurk in or two in there i think that's
what they're going to drop off i'm
hoping
i'm saying but i really hope it's a
secret invasion i think we'll get a
little secret in fact
i'm not participating in this game i
think they've had that they've had that
cut for a while yeah this is this is not
your question but i'm getting there i'm
subverting it here what full trailers
are we getting tomorrow
i i mean
black panther and and she-hulk is almost
it feels
like a second or third trailer if you
see hulk you're saying the next series
is secret invasion right afterwards
yes i think they'll have a trailer
holiday special guardians of the galaxy
comes before secret invasion
werewolf by night hasn't even been
announced yet we
polls we asked some polls what's more
like the young avengers uh 73 percent of
you said young avengers whoa
i tend to agree wait wait okay the other
one was a little closer 53 percent of
you think uh it'll be secret in fact
versus loki season two interesting
yeah yeah i always just say uh we know
that um
ironheart is shooting uh shits fire
[Music]
that could that could certainly make it
problems on set like something could be
on fire or is that noted
we got night cream versus [ __ ] ice cream
um uh okay uh there's we think there
might also be some unannounced films
getting uh release dates or confirmed
things or whatever what do you think is
more likely we get a confirmed release
date for uh the next spider-man film you
know they're always thirsty to talk
about spider-man uh as we saw today or
the next captain america film release
date when are we getting we don't know
when those are coming out we have a we
have a confirmed screenwriter we know
they're working for captain america and
a director and a director and i believe
they've sort of said like we really want
the same team to come back for
spider-man so i think both of them have
you know that period sony's been trying
to get the news out there they're like
yeah tom allen's coming back don't you
oh yeah oh yeah he hasn't signed his
contract but that's okay yeah okay we
just haven't given him the pen uh i'm
going to say both because marvel may not
want to be
uh
literally no no i'm not saying both i'm
still
i'm listing two reasons
marvel doesn't want to be born of the
spot of the sony movie too hard yeah
and because we got that recent uh
director and writer confirmation i think
i think captain america film is what
they'll announce i think so too yeah i i
i started to jump in there before
everyone's giving their answers i think
that makes the most sense yeah sorry you
agree you agree captain america i'll say
spider-man oh whoa
i think they want to like calm
everyone's nose you make a good point i
think that people are feeling antsy and
they want to they want to walk away
they're
marvel wasn't gonna be a comic-con they
decided to come back i think they really
wanna drop some some cards on the table
and say nice try dc we're doing it nice
try don't use web
if they give us a black panther two
trailer
and nothing else that's enough they've
dropped the mic on dc don't you probably
probably probably and even one casting
one casting piece of news don't you
think it depends on what they show in
the trailer right speaking of dc though
uh we do get the warner brothers panel
tomorrow we know black adam and shazam
fury of the gods will be there but
do we think it's more likely that dc
announces a new superman project henry
cavill rumored to make an appearance
at comic-con tomorrow or do we think
they'll announce the next zack schneider
new project
fire up your twitter bots yeah
well there was a new story today that
supposedly someone from warner brothers
has said that like they're not even
thinking about their normal zack snyder
thing no yes i think there's a zero
percent likelihood on that but i also
think the chance of a new superman thing
is zero percent i think i think the
chances are better that henry cavill is
at comic-con to buy some backings
than it is to announce a new superman
movie or maybe witcher stuff or that
guy's got a lot of other projects but um
that'd be interesting yeah it doesn't
feel like either of these is super i
feel great about you the eu i really
hope warner brothers says like here's
what we we're going to do for the next
seven years and it makes sense to us you
know yeah i i think like right now three
more batman we talked about this
yesterday different batman i don't know
what i don't know what direction they're
going in it feels like they don't know
what direction they're going yeah okay
the chat thinks it's going to be
they're still voting they're still
voting but they did say that captain
america
lean in hard new superman over a new
zack snyder he did say next captain
america film uh over spider-man 83 and
here we go same same sort of ratio with
next superman i think it's superman film
i don't think yes they're good starring
michael b jordan as black suits
yeah he's been kind of out there
campaigning and talking about getting
school for creed3
okay um in the play on is this your king
yeah
okay this is your quicker you know
uh okay a couple more uh before we wrap
this up uh who's more likely to make a
surprise appearance we know henry cavill
is rumored but do we think we'll get a
bat fleck uh more likely batfleck or
little lady gaga
as a potential harley quinn for the
joker sequel lady gaga comes out and
does a full song
and harley quinn yeah as harley quinn
yeah
i think lady gaga because uh beth lake
is off on his honeymoon probably with uh
jayla good call they could go
to san diego san diego
if i had that kind of money and again
that guy's even more failed out than
zack snyder there's zero chances i did i
disagree i think schneiderlin he's got a
new wife he's gotta gotta make some
money
you know he's possibly sober right now
he's feeling impossible we don't know we
don't know okay i i didn't write this
question but i'm going to read it
once more yeah go for it okay what's
more likely to happen to the rocket
comic con we know he's going to be there
what's more likely to happen to him he's
going to announce black adam 2 or the
tribal chief roman reigns appears and
cuts a promo on the rock setting up
roman reigns versus the rock at
wrestlemania 2023 which will be in los
angeles
[Music]
well i think very unlikely that warner
brothers chooses to use their panel
to promote a w
but that will get so many eyes on their
panel it's it's free promotion i don't
think black adam two is gonna happen so
that's what i'm saying you know
you don't you don't think it will happen
you don't think black adam's gonna do
well enough sorry i i don't mean that
they won't greenlight a second movie
before they have box office numbers i
think they might pre-announce it just to
get the hype going the same company
warner brothers did well no they didn't
do that for dune they waited to see how
doom one did before they literally just
now started working on two which is
insane
um
yeah ah
i got them too i i agree i think they're
gonna be tentative i mean that's a black
adam's a risk it's a gamble it's not a
super popular character we don't know i
mean everybody loves the rock and that
look the trailer looked good but we
don't know we don't know okay last one
uh who's more likely to i'm skipping a
couple of these uh who's more likely to
appear next to kevin feige on stage in a
sort of blade moment do we think taryn
edgerton as wolverine
or a possible keanu reeves as a silver
surfer announcement yeah we know we're
getting fantastic for we know we're
getting x-men either one of these we're
on years of fan casting speculation
they've been doing a little fan casting
lately we know keanu is sort of like in
talks all the time to do stuff i mean if
they want we know they're doing
fantastic four and if they want to like
tease that it's gonna be galactus story
saying you got keanu as a silver surfer
would be pretty pretty insane oh i think
you're gonna say keanu as galactus i
mean that'd be a whole other story yeah
that'd be a whole other story i don't
think we're gonna get galactus for like
another 10 years
they got they got
some other villains
yeah and and again that the rumored
copyrighted uh or whatever movie titles
kang plays a prominent role in at least
one of them kang dynasty
was one of those i mean that sounds so
goofy
to me it sounded goofy and i was like
this is not what they're going to call
it it could have been copyrighting for
like a snack at marvel's campaign
we were also we were watching the 2019
panel brandon and i the other day and
the the captain america civil war title
they had originally flashed on the
screen as it was
society yeah it was known as that for a
while leading into that comic con and
then he you know kevin feige very
cheekily he's like we got a better title
for it so that was the working title
well they just held the spot as like
yeah this is going to be captain america
serpent society they put that out there
was a logo there was everything but we
know these logos mean nothing too
because even the shows they do they
change the logo every three months as
they're like well this show's actually
gonna be more like this so we're gonna
change the logo a little bit uh so yeah
i don't believe any of those trademark
things we saw earlier earlier today
red herrings all of them and again i
will say we're not really covering it
because again it's pretty speculative
and we don't know if it means anything
but like in that list of
possible copyright names two avengers
things in there it's like avengers kang
dynasty avengers secret invasion secret
wars secret warriors apologies yeah yeah
we're already getting secret invasion as
a disney plus series um so who knows boy
that would be big if like phase five
is like that's the
infinity war end game of phase five or
something like that you also got to
think like marvel knows that this stuff
would come out before their big day at
comic-con yeah you know they wouldn't i
i don't know it feels so the timing's
really good i do love the like friday
afternoon
uh league of legends someone just like
hit publish is like the last possible
time the lawyer can sneak it into the
patent office before the weekend comes
you know
um either way
we're again we're going to be covering
this live tomorrow myself eric john will
be here jessica clemons will be here
the all age panel is not streaming live
anywhere no the best you can do is be
refreshing twitter lame
instead watch watch us refresh twitter
okay it'll be like you're you're getting
the news with your your buddies at new
first is the panel at five are you guys
starting when the package specific
we'll be running concurrently with that
at the beginning we'll recap the
previous earlier in the day the warner
brothers panel where maybe roman reigns
showed up and uh spear
his cousin the rock um and then in real
time we will be reporting on everything
that comes up from the marvel live
action panel in exciting glory we do can
we zip through what if and and marvel
zombies
we'll talk whatever
season two's coming 2023
yeah very soon
uh
uh we're gonna see they watched the
whole episode i guess today and it was
uh it was maybe the episode that was cut
from season one is that where we were we
don't know it was it was uh sharon
carter versus the hydro stopper that was
the episode they showed we don't know
there was a lego involved with that that
like came out that was never one of the
episodes wasn't there also like a game
stuff that we never saw that was also a
lego
minifig that came out so i don't know uh
but we're gonna be seeing captain carter
again uh and they confirmed at this
panel uh that this is not the same peggy
carter from multiverse of madness that
one died if you recall she was cut in
half
but this is a different one this one's
much smarter uh but i guess uh this what
if is going to be what if uh
uh captain carter fought the hydra
stomper which i guess is a redo of like
the first episode well it'll be at the
at the end of what if if you remember
she's like looking in right to the but
that's in the future when they found him
again i imagine they're just gonna pick
up from where i don't know we'll see
we'll have to see uh
uh there was also um a trailer released
for what if uh and it's said to have uh
marvel 1602 which was a really cool
comic this is not online this is not
online the trailer is not online we
don't know when they'll put it online
maybe tomorrow uh
uh but this showed like they're gonna do
a what if based on this great comic book
run called marvel 1602 which is based on
like some of the marvel characters being
alive in elizabethan yeah neil gaiman
wrote the original comic it featured
crazy stuff like uh doctor doom
poisoning elizabeth the first yeah yeah
very strange stuff with doctor strange
and khalia strange involved very
exciting uh they also showed in this
trailer we saw a sequence with like
asgardians versus chongqi characters uh
there was this like crazy road race that
looked like fury road
uh
very cool stuff um and they've already
announced that there will be a season
three of what if uh and that has been
ordered
with season two coming out yeah i love
you
what it was surprisingly great really
like and so far the first kind of like
disney plus uh marvel animated stuff and
it was a big success yeah
it did really well uh we also got news
that there's um gonna be like a marvel
zombie show which is a spin-off of the
uh original show of the episode of what
of what if that showed the zombies i
guess joshua we have some assets i've
been running through this so quick show
some assets so these are some of the
characters i mentioned the non-zombie
characters i love
uh red guardian great to see him coming
back so fun to see these like characters
get used again
um
some of the villains we're gonna see in
this zombie show through some of the are
these the villains yes yeah we got an
abomination
captain marvel
is that the ancient one or is that a
curly witch
um winter soldier there yeah
legs have no legs no leg caps that's the
strongest asset is the mag
america's butt no americans
oh no take me out i don't need it i
don't need to live in this world anymore
america's guts hanging out of the torso
there's icarus as a half zombie i guess
they were saying like he could only be
half zombie because he's still a robot
but i guess whatever
organic material he's made of can be
zombified you think he'd be like um and
then there's just like some zombie road
racers well it's like it looks like
i don't know uh very cool very cool um
if you uh want to go a little bit more
in depth into some of the stuff that was
announced today eric vos's video out on
the channel yeah sort of going into the
comics history of some of these things
and and talking more about all this
stuff in detail you'll see some some
assets from comic books yeah he'll give
a lot more information and it goes
without saying any trailers that come
out
tomorrow eric ross can we bring you down
the hell out of those uh going into all
kinds of depth we'll we'll get that to
you on the new rockstars channel as soon
as possible
uh and it seems like you guys were in a
poll are most excited about the
asgardians versus chongqi
characters uh which i think will be very
cool
and whatnot yeah yeah uh excited to see
more of that uh we also got a trailer
for real quick oh yeah do we see a goats
versus dragons fight maybe like the
screaming gods versus the dragon i mean
if the screaming girl or no bulldogs
versus uh goats would make a lot more
sense oh yeah that's the food
anything maybe the souls will come back
morris versus uh
[Laughter]
uh we also got a trailer for i am groot
uh this is gonna be five episodes they
all drop on august 10th they're short
little like mini episodes bradley cooper
is voicing rocket in it it's super cute
uh ben diesel is groot again but like we
kind of said it's canon
white
it's listed in its own canon it's it's
baby groot so it's like in between uh
it's before infinity war
uh yeah after volume two i guess is when
it's kind of taking place somewhere in
the times of volume this trailer is
released to the public you can yeah you
can go find the trailer they watched the
first episode there they said it was
very cute groot takes a bath adorable
sweet adorable baby group uh sweet sweet
baby groot uh but that's a lot of the
big news from today uh tons of exciting
stuff tons of animated stuff coming um
i'm excited to see it yeah it's gonna be
a big big san diego comic-con weekend
yeah um thank you all for watching with
us uh and and sitting through our
discussions our uh i hope your friday
and going well yes we hope you have big
weekend plans or if not that you at
least have a nice peaceful restful
weekend we're going to be back tomorrow
little over 24 hours from now to cover
live the studio h marvel live action
panel and then monday i mean you heard
it have some extra pants on hand because
you'll be
you'll be blasting your way through at
least one bear
breaker during tomicon okay tommy
bechtold will be fully unleashed he will
be at his most tommy uh it will be a
ridiculous episode we'll also be
recapping the comic-con news of the week
we'll have some news on monday a little
bit of news there will be a little bit
of news
yes uh go ahead and turn your volumes
down right now just get ready for that
it's gonna be a loud one bump it down uh
but uh to thank you uh so much for
watching all week long thank you eric uh
john brandon and all the folks are on
angelica trey jessica clements tommy
bechdel everybody else that was on this
week uh and all of you for watching we
want to leave you with our clip of the
week
um this is a fun one it was one of our
favorite highlights from this week of
break room shows you can submit your
favorite clips on our discord do it um
we're gonna start doing this every week
i think the clip of the week yeah yeah
great thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow
we've invented some incredible
technologies here at new rockstars and
i wanted to introduce our next
incredible achievement in engineering
wow
animatronic eric voss wow we have taken
all of the voice recordings of eric voss
thank you you can see him demoed right
here we've taken all of the voice
recordings of eric voss and a skin that
is close
and put him into this incredible
animatronic
welcome back to you rock stars today i'm
breaking down gummy bears the cartoon
episode six the bears melt
some cakes to be worked out but we'll
see you next year also blaze must
destroy philip must destroy phil kill
phillip kill up molina kill up molina
new rockstars